نسمع عن الهجمات السيبرانيه او حتى
الالكترونيه لكن لنتعرف مشاهدينا اكثر على
هذه
المصطلحات او هذا المصطلح تحديدا هذا
الهجوم محاوله متعمده من جانب فرد او
مؤسسه او دوله ما لاختراق نظام المعلومات
لدى جهه اخرى وهي بدورها قد تكون فردا او
شركه او حتى دوله هناك عدد من الانواع
الشائعه من الهجمات السيبرانيه منها
البرامج الضاره او الخبيثه بما في ذلك
برامج التجسس وبرامج الفديه الهجمات
السيبرانيه ومنذ وقت ليس بالقليل اصبحت
جزءا من الحرب الالكترونيه التي تقوم بها
الدول ضد خصومها من هنا يصبح الهجوم
السيبراني سلاحا بمقدوره احداث اضرار
جسيمه وطويله الامد مثل الاطاحه بنظام حكم
او التمهيد لحرب او تخريب قطاعات تؤثر على
حياه السكان ومع ازدياد حده المواجهه
السيبرانيه بين الاول وفي حالتي السلمي او
الحرب تتنافس الدول على تعزيز مكانتها
وتوفير قدرات تؤهلها لشن هجمات سيبرانيه
مدمره وفي ذات الوقت تضع حكومات الدول
المختلفه الامن السيبراني في قلب
استراتيجيات الامن القومي الذي بات جزءا
مهما من حمايه الدول نشير اخيرا الى ان
الخسائر الماليه جراء الهجمات الالكترونيه
خلال العام الماضي تجاوزت عشره مليارات
دولار تخيلوا هذا الرقم بحسب تقرير لمكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكي لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات